good morning believe nation are you
having a bad day hopefully this video
will help clip number one is my personal
favorite and at the end of the video I
shared my thoughts as well and as always
as you guys are watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave in the comments below for
quotes around it other people can be
inspired as well enjoy have you ever got
in the middle of your day and things
just fell apart and you're just like I
need a restart no you just wanted to
start the whole day over you were
thinking things were kind of going good
and now I'm derailed I got distracted I
stopped doing what I was supposed to be
doing I had a bad interaction with
somebody or a conflict and I feel bad
about myself or about the day and you
just overall were frustrated with where
you're at and you were struggling to
restart a lot of people don't have the
resiliency to restart in the middle of
the day and so they lose those last
couple hours or the rest of the entire
day to a bad mood too bad energy too bad
productivity too being ineffective and
because of that it's costing us great
amounts of progress in our own personal
lives and frankly as a country a nation
an economy we struggle with it a lot
people have need to become more
resilient so what can you do
Oh
[Music]
we all want to be able to change the way
we feel that's what I spend my life
showing people how to do and what most
people know is the emotion is created by
motion the way you move determines the
way you feel you have 80 different
muscles in your face 80 for most people
this is the largest area of unemployment
in the country they used to make the
face the same way they feel the same
emotions over and over and over again so
what I was saying is I just deal with
myself called priming every day I feel
up you've got to have 10 minutes for
yourself you're impendence yourself you
don't have a life and I'm not going to
hope I feel good I know I just got back
six countries in 12 days over than India
two days ago laughs I woke up here like
feeling up somebody ran me over with a
shot thank you have sight but the way it
is is I do this process it's ten minutes
and put some music on I do this massive
change in my breathing so it radically
changes the way I feel and then I do
this three step process first I do three
minutes of gratitude where I think of
three things I'm really grateful for and
I associate I don't think of it of that
I feel it and the reason is when you're
grateful you can't be worried it can't
be fearful when you're grateful you
can't be angry and anger and fear what
screw people up most in their
relationships in their life in their
business so I wire myself I think to you
that most people want to be happy but
their habit is to be worried or pissed
off or frustrated or stress and so
they're they've got a high way to stress
and they got a dirt road to happiness
so I wire myself I've got a highway to
gratitude which changes all your
emotions and then I do three-minute
process has kind of a prayer for my
family and friends and I do a
three-minute process of the top three
things I want to accomplish I see it is
done I feel I'm done in 10 minutes so
sometimes I go 20 but my deal is 10 so
there's no excuse not to do it you know
what I think it's a great way to kind of
set the tone for the game does it change
it changes listen we've all had time for
you snapped at somebody and you felt bad
because it wasn't them it was the state
you're in right well there's no excuse
for that if you prime yourself you set
yourself up they've done studies where
they go to people and they have a man
walk up to you and say could you hold
this for me hand you a cup of coffee
it's an actor and they takes it takes a
man's pocket then he takes it back into
thank you hundred people they do it with
ice coffee
how do people deal with hot coffee 45
minutes later another actor comes by and
says listen we're doing this little test
for $5.00 would you read this three
paragraphs and answer three questions
most people say yes it's a little story
questions are about the character what's
the character like 80% of people got
iced coffee say the person is cold and
mean Wow 81% of the people that got hot
coffee say the person is warm and gentle
or nice that's how much we can be primed
by our environment we think we're just
feeling what you're feeling but our
environment if we don't take control of
our environment it takes control with us
there's a ton of bad days being an
entrepreneur not to mention 98% of
entrepreneurial ventures are going to
fail so there's gonna be a really bad
day in your future you know hopefully
not for you
or any of you you know for me I don't
know I think it's a very personal
question I think it's how you're wired
I'm so all-in entrepreneur I prefer the
pain I think one of the reasons I love
the jet so much is because they bring me
so much pain you know I I love the climb
I mean the setback is exciting I love
when something goes wrong it's where I
shine the most but that's not for
everybody right I mean it could be very
difficult and when you start affecting
your life and your loved ones and all
the other things it can get real nasty
to me the way I handle things even to
the few rare days when I really struggle
I take a real step back and make pretend
that somebody called me and told me that
my mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I can make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin and
and if something bad happened to the
people I love the most then it would
mean nothing and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's money
for me it's not really money it's my
legacy so I get hurt by it a little bit
more but uh yeah I mean that's you know
I put in perspective it's money and you
know what up until
I had a daughter even while I was
married up until one I have Nisha
four years ago I secretly wanted to lose
all my money I had this weird twisted
dark fantasy of losing everything just
to rise again like a phoenix and remind
you w toh what's the opportunity here so
you're having a bad day maybe you had a
fight with someone maybe you lost a big
sale maybe someone cut you off in
traffic and then you didn't get your
favorite favorite lunch and then you
miss getting into SoulCycle class and
then you had a difficulty on the way
home so let's say that's happening you
simply run the WT o H question which
will allow you to pivot W toh what's the
opportunity here see there's great power
in a question and it allows your brain
to hunt for something good and so how do
you pivot you ask yourself what's the
opportunity here you have a fight with
someone let's say one of your family
members you say what's the opportunity
here well your brain then starts to look
for the opportunity which is I can learn
how to communicate better or this is an
opportunity for me to show forgiveness
and grow in my personal bravery this is
an opportunity for me to understand my
family member better it's a great and
powerful question if I need to reset I
realized the day is all gone to crap I
will immediately stop everything if the
day has gone to crap don't stay in your
inbox don't keep doing the same thing
you're doing take a step away from from
it literally go outside take a walk my
favorite recess I have two of them one I
go outside I take my phone I put on my
favorite playlist of music and I don't
think about anything
all I just listed the music and I walk
for 20 minutes when I come back to my
dad or I come back to the house or come
back to wherever I was I sit down I bust
out my journal and I write three things
number one I start writing everything
I'm grateful because I'm trying to take
my mind off of the day so that's why I
listen to the music with no thoughts
just listening the lyrics music
breathing as I'm walking sit down
what am i grateful for second what three
things must be accomplished today write
those down
third what's my reward if I accomplish
those three things and for me my reward
is social so I say if I finish these
three as soon as I finish these three
things I get to call my best friends
from school who I haven't seen in years
if I finish these three things I get to
call my lady if I finish these three
things I get to get up I get to go have
some green tea and some chocolate it's
enough whatever it is for you you need
to have that rewear I write those down
and it reengaged me with the blessings
of life reengage we want to accomplish
Andrey engages me with a simple reward
that's my first favorite way to reset my
second favorite way to reset is
meditation to just stop everything close
my eyes do the release meditation
technique again learn that before you
can learn it from me on YouTube doesn't
my name and police meditation technique
and I do that for 20 when I opened up my
eyes I stand I stretch I get some water
I come back and again I write those
three things what I'm grateful for what
three things must be accomplished today
and ultimately what's our reward for
doing this that's a great way to reset I
would say another one is to get outside
of your head to stop thinking it all has
to be you accomplishing everything for
you and another great reset is to ask
the simple question what could I do
right now
to give a surprise some attention or
some gratitude and appreciation to
somebody around me good could I go thank
the receptionist someone who I have
talked to for a while can I go pull a
prank on a friend over here can I call
somebody and prank them and make a joke
with them can I call somebody randomly
and say thank you can I sit down this
writer a random thank-you email to
somebody haven't talked to four other
guys shoot an iPhone video sending love
to family or friend get outside of
myself and in service or surprise to
somebody else helps me reboot the day
because it gives me a social enthusiasm
to engage with with the day as I was
growing up as a child I would be quite
envious of everybody else around me who
had arms and legs including my brother
and sister at times I was born without
limbs for no medical reason there were
times in life where things happen and
don't make sense and I was just sitting
on a plane seat next to this guy who was
going to visit his mom and his
stepfather just died on Friday they're
burying him tomorrow or the day after
and you know was talking with him a
little bit and you know there are just
some things that we weren't
understanding this life though there are
some times where you're going to wish
that you could rewind and and do things
all over again there are times where you
just wish you could forget memories and
you try to drown those memories in
alcohol or different pleasures and maybe
get distracted by the goals and
ambitions of your life and try to put
the past behind and move forward we're
all human beings please don't get me
wrong I don't wake up every morning with
a smile on my face like hi everybody
I have ups and downs you see my foot ups
and downs ups now the first thing I want
you to take away from today is this you
will have good days and you'll have bad
days but you will always learn something
more or something new and you will learn
more overall on bad days than good days
you will learn more about yourself
you'll learn more about relationships
you'll learn about life and principles
and it will build your character if
you're a person who wants to let's say
improve on your character of patience
let's say don't complain when you're
waiting in a line you ain't going to
growing patience until you put in a
place to wait it's like you go into a
gym and you know you're walking through
the front doors and you know you tell
your wife or your husband I'm going to
the gym you go into the gym and you come
in three
do a u-turn in your right out I went to
the gym ain't going to do nothing you
got to go with and what are you going to
do you're going to pick up the weight
and you exercise the muscles that you
want to build I stand before you without
arms and legs but a very strong man
because of the bad days of my life
you know how it is if you didn't go what
you've gone through you wouldn't be who
you are today and I'm not belittling
your pain and don't worry I've seen pain
in my life and I've seen not only in my
life but people's lives and people say
well at least I have no arms or legs and
what am I supposed to say well at least
I'm not an African orphan who's dying at
four years old and I met that person
what about the ten year old girl that
was bought for seven hundred US dollars
in Mumbai and kidnapped as a sex slaves
had 350 clients before the age of 13
pregnant had 12 put the baby under the
bed while she works on top abandoned by
a family after she pays the debt at
seven hundred US dollars after three
years with her child she leaves on the
streets of Mumbai hoping for a new life
no family no job no food her baby needs
food she gets raped beating up on the
street she comes back to the only way
that she knows how to make money she
goes back to the brothels she gets
pregnant at 15 the second time and then
that child dies and they're 20 years old
she comes up to me yes I have met this
woman she comes up crying she says Nick
I just found out I got hiv/aids and I
got fine from being a prostitute what do
you say to that you may have arms and
legs but unless you know three things
number one who are you and what your
value is number two what is your purpose
here in life and number three what is
your destiny when you're done here if
you don't know the answers of any of
those three questions you're more
disabled than I so my quick thoughts are
I think it's generally good to try to
avoid having bad days or bad moments
especially
when they are happening frequently I
think anybody can have a bad day and I
think in general you can use some of the
strategies in this video to help you
take those bad days and just chunk those
in the bad moment so it doesn't bleed
into the entire day or the next day but
one thing that I try to pay particular
attention to is if I'm feeling like this
for multiple days in a row if that's
happening consistently that I know
something needs to change if I'm getting
up when I'm looking in the mirror and
I'm not happy for multiple days in a row
or I'm looking at my schedule of all the
things that I need to do and I'm not
excited by it and I'm not motivated by
it and I know that something needs to
change and that's not to say that every
moment is amazing and I look forward to
every single thing that I'm ever going
to do in my life there's a lot of crap
that comes with running a business a lot
of things that are not so good a lot of
things that can get you down but on the
surface like on the whole you should
feel like the work you're doing is
meaningful matters you're growing you're
having a contribution and you're excited
about the work that you're doing because
if you're not you're not going to
continue it's just going to fade away
your business won't have success if you
don't have the passion for it and so
what I think it's okay I think it's okay
to switch gears I think it takes
actually a lot of courage that you would
switch gears I think it takes a lot of
courage to start off on some path that
you thought you would enjoy and then as
you get into it you realize hah this
isn't actually for me but I'm going to
keep on this path that is not for me
because I already invested all this time
and money and effort into it or I've
already told my friends and family that
I'm going to do this and it would look
really bad if I stop now those are the
wrong reasons to do it just because you
put a ton of energy into something
doesn't mean you should keep doing it
just because you're worried about
looking bad in front of somebody it
doesn't mean you should keep doing it
take that thing that you no longer like
and if you can sell it if you can get
rid of it if you can give it to somebody
else great and if not dump it I move on
with something else I have I have left
more projects I've left more youtube
series than a lot of people even ever
dare to create and it's part of the
process as you grow as you evolve as you
become a higher version of yourself as
other interests come in your business
and the work that you do can't
stagnant you need to change the work
that you do as you grow and evolve as a
human being and so I find it super
valuable and super helpful that if I'm
ever feeling down for any consistent
period of time to look at the work that
I'm doing and evaluate it and say is
that still worth actually doing is that
still worth my time if I'm not motivated
to go out and do something and that's
consistent and I need to find a way to
get rid of it and move on and go do
something else that does ignite me that
does get me excited because that is
where the magic is going to happen for
me and for you the more you are feeling
in the zone in the moment amazed at the
work that you're doing creative
impactful the more you're there that is
where the magic is going to happen for
your business for your life so try to
stay there as much as possible
and eliminate the things that are
causing these bad dating porn so thank
you guys so much for watching this
edition to believe life I made it
because Priya asked me to so there's a
topic you'd like me to cover in the next
edition of believe life leave your
requests in the comment below and we'll
see what we can do
I'm also curious what do you guys do
when you have a bad day what's your
solution to get out of it what are some
of the strategies and tactics that you
use to bring yourself back up whether
that's a mindset thing a scheduling
thing what do you do to get out of a bad
day leave it in the comments below
I'm curious and I think you'll also be
able to help others going through
similar problems finally I want to give
a quick shout out to a tool petrea a
tool thank you so much for creating that
artwork around my book your one word I
really appreciate the love time with
energy that went into it and just want
to say thank you so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon